this is where it's all going to happen
and these are the seats set aside for
the hundreds of journalists are going to
be traveling from around the world to
cover this case this is the dock where
they accused Oscar Pistorius will be
standing and fighting for his freedom
he'll be just behind his defense team
some of the finest legal brains in South
Africa are defending him they are just
behind the state lawyers the prosecution
team who are fighting to convince the
judge the Oscar Pistorius intended to
kill his girlfriend reeva Steenkamp the
judge will be sitting here with two
Assessors to help her and the witnesses
will be their state witnesses will be
televised it's only oscar pistorius and
the defense who have the right not to be
televised although we will hear all
their evidence for the first time
they'll be cameras recording proceedings
live as it happens one camera there one
camera there and another one behind it
is South African history in the making
and they're calling it the trial of the
century and you can watch it all and
hear it all on Sky News